e
e e
okay we'll open up the public Hearing in
House Bill 451 and hear from the prime
sponsor representative evil good morning
representative evil okay good morning Mr
chair
uh the
committee I'm pleased to be back before
Commerce um for the record uh my name is
Karen eel I represent marac district 7
um I'm here to introduce HB
451 which would establish a postc
consumer paint stewardship program I did
uh give the committee a copy of my
statement I left it by the clerk's
position there
and I also provided you with a copy of
the most recent report interim report of
the solid waste working group um and I
am
here I'm here in my capacity as chair of
the solid waste working
group so if
you okay I'll just wait so if you wanted
to distribute the report that would
provide the uh that's it that would
provide the committee with a copy of the
stakeholder membership of the solid
waste working group which basically um
we have representa representatives from
um uh landfill operators
recyclers uh
municipalities we have someone from UNH
we have many many people so what I bring
forward um a bill that is supported by
the solid waste working group I think
it's important to note that um it's a
bill that has broad support within the
industry and within the various
stakeholder
groups um this bill uh as I said would
create a postc consumer paint
stewardship program it's a fully
bipartisan bill as you can see um and it
follows the Prototype that's used in
many other states by paint manufacturers
and the related stewardship
organizations it is uh supported by the
paint industry and there is a
representative of the American codings
association with us today who can talk
uh to you about the program in much
greater detail than I can but as an
overview uh consumers can bring their
leftover paint and related products to
participating retailers
there's absolutely no requirement that
the retailers participate it is
voluntary and folks can come and bring
their paint there for recycling
similarly
municipalities which host uh expensive
Hol household hazardous waste collection
days which many of you may be familiar
with can turn over the paint That's
brought in for disposal by their
residents to the manufacturer created
steward ship Organization for
recycling I will say and you'll you'll
hear more about this about half of all
households hazardous waste I'm going to
call it hHw because easier to say um
that's collected is paint and in
addition to uh the ability of consumers
to bring in their paint for recycling
businesses can also bring in their paint
for recycling and that includes small
and large entities once the program is
up and running as I said anyone can
bring in their paint for recycling and
it is true that uh you can bring it you
can bring all the paint that you have
gathering in your basement to the uh
program for
recycling even if you bought the uh the
um substances prior to the program being
initiated there is a small search charge
on the paint That's charged at the point
of purch purch that funds the program
and it's payable at the time of sale the
sear charges help to fund the program
and those uh sear charges and we've
worked very closely with Dees on this
bill would entirely defay any
administrative expenses by Dees and what
you can see uh from the fiscal note
those expenses are very minimal about
$50,000 and actually uh there's very
little um administrative responsibility
that for falls on the
agency um as I mentioned we worked
closely with Dees in the development of
the bill we did get their technical
advice um over the course of quite a few
drafts um and their input on the
structure and implementation plan for
the bill and uh the staff is here today
to respond to any specific questions the
committee might have from from their
stand
point we work very
collaboratively um with industry and
with the agency in the development of
that bill so the next important thing is
to just note the dees recently adopted a
new Solid Waste Management plan to help
guide the state through its solid waste
management issues and challenges over
the next several years one of the
important uh goals or purposes of the
solid waste working group is to work
with Dees just generally as a resource
for them but also to help put fourth
legislation that supports the goals of
the solid waste management plan this
bill supports the goals of the diversion
of um hazardous waste as well just for
recycling and also it diverts it from um
from being put in landfills over time
additionally it should help with
improper dumping of paint and paint
related products our groundwater and our
soil obviously isn't a good place for
these products paint can contain many
toxics and unfortunately folks do get
frustrated trying to figure out what to
do with it and sometimes they can um
improperly dispose of it and I will say
that it's an ongoing uh issue for
consumers who have paint in their
basements they don't know what to do
with it they really want to do the right
thing there we have a regional Facebook
group in my area and two or three people
last week POS the question what the heck
am I supposed to do with this paint so
um it is a common and frequent problem
and consumers definitely are interested
in doing the right thing um the next
thing I just want to point out is that
this bill is both industry and business
supported um we all benefit when we help
our citizens appropriately deal with
these products as I mentioned the
American codings Association
representative is here and uh the paint
manufacturers agree they've created a
nonprofit specifically to Steward post
consumer paint it's called Paint care
and um as I mentioned we worked with
both their industry and Dees in the
development of the bill so the bill that
you have before you is is a model for
the paint Care Program which uh operates
throughout the United States many
hardware stores uh from a business
standpoint they sell they sell paint and
there is there is support among uh small
hardware stores they like this recycling
program because actually when they bring
the paint when folks bring the paint to
the retailers um if they choose to part
participate the retailers uh folks can
bring in their paint um and it builds
foot traffic for the hardware stores and
for that reason you find many um smaller
businesses participating in the takeback
program and um they like it a
lot um from the standpoint of the bill
history this bill uh a similar uh
concept of this um idea came before
House of environment and agriculture
last term it passed uh unanimously out
of that committee it was on the consent
calendar and it passed unanimously out
of the house last year um the chair of
environment and a is here to talk about
um her committee's view on the bill and
so if you have specific questions there
you can ask um you can ask
her lastly um this benefits
municipalities it will save tax and it
should save tax dollar taxpayer dollars
and from your own experience you know
you know that towns or groups of towns
hold periodic household hazardous waste
collection days and as you also know
there can be some uh uh I don't know
impatience around those do those those
days because people want to do the right
thing and they only occur at a very
periodic basis and as I mentioned paint
is about half of what is collected
during those days and what happens is
the towns sometimes they get Grant
programs sometimes they don't or the
regions uh operate them they basically
collect the uh hazardous waste and then
they have to deal with its disposal they
have to pay for it and it's extremely
expensive for the towns so um you'll
also see in the fiscal note while it's
very hard to estimate um this could be a
taxpayer savings
um program for our towns and I know that
there are folks that can speak more uh
definitively about that and also the New
Hampshire Municipal Association is
supportive of this measure just uh
lastly you know once the paint is
collected it ends up too at these
household hazardous waste events um too
frequently it ends up in landfills along
with all the containers that it comes in
the state recently adopted Solid Waste
diversion goals we're trying to divert
25% in weight from our landfills and
waste to energy plants landfills um as
you know have been a Hot Topic around
here and anything that we can do to
preserve our uh landfill capacity would
be terrific if we can conserve it for
those things that really need to be
landfill because unfortunately some
things just do um paint does not have to
be landfilled and it can be recycled and
we should take advantage of recycling
any commodity that we can and then very
lastly uh for the committee um I want to
say that this has very broad coalition
report we worked very hard to get um to
get interested parties to step forward
to indicate that report I'm proud to
present to you a bill that um has been
supported not only by the ACA uh but the
business and industry Association the
national waste recycling Association
Waste Management cassella as I mentioned
the New Hampshire Municipal
Association the the conservation law
Foundation a Consortium of Statewide en
environmental groups that includes the
society for the protection of New
Hampshire Forest nature conservancy and
the aabon society among others and I can
say with some assurity that that there
this collection of folks probably hasn't
stood together um universally supporting
a bill many times in the past this
indicates that that the management of
solid waste is neither partisan nor is
concerned for it uh just related to
particular interest groups everybody has
an issue with solid waste they use
products and they generate it and I
think it behooves all of us to do better
with um with our trash so on that basis
um I'm pleased to bring before you a
carefully crafted broadly supported
bipartisan bill and I urge the committee
to support its passage and I'm happy to
take any
questions represent
spear this is actually a a curiosity
question when you say that this the
paint can be recycled that means when
when it goes to one of these collection
places it's not going to go in the
landfill I I take it and somehow some
organization is going to do what with it
they're not going to throw it in a
landfill are they no obviously yeah
death that's the point of this program
um and the the um representative of the
ACA is here and she can take talk in
Greater detail about what happens but
basically um the and this is another
issue for municipalities is the ISS the
issue and the cost of hauling but they
arrange for the collection from The
Collection sites and they bring it to a
recycling facility so from the time that
a consumer or a business turns over the
paint their responsibility the paint
care uh organization responsibility
kicks in and um they'll take it over and
obviously they're supporting this
program because they feel that is
worthwhile to recycle the paint and um
from that standpoint again you know when
you think about it it's really good to
be recycling things that we shouldn't be
throwing away representative burrow
thanks for taking my question before I
do that I just want to say this is an
amazing piece of work it really is and I
my hat off to you bringing all these
people together um representative spear
asked half my question are the buckets
also recy cycled yes okay
thanks representative Henry um is there
any anything in this program that uh
pays people to collect this stuff and
bring it
in um I'm not quite sure what you mean
but the um well actually I was just
chatting with the with the ACA
representative if and she again can give
you more details about that but you're
if a you're if you're a a large
generator of paint you can arrange with
the with the paint care folks to come
and pick up the paint
um free of charge but as far as going
around and picking it up from
Individual homeowners or businesses
no I mean it's a volume question
representative M uh thank you very much
real quick question you said that a a
paint store or hardware store can
voluntarily into the program and take it
take the paint back would they be a if
they didn't V unteer to be in the
program would they be allowed to to
charge that se charge the SE charge
would be a universal SE charge on all
paint products sold in the state thank
you and that's where I want to go I
figured okay so we're about to pass a
sales tax and would you please tell me
how this is going to be collected I read
in the bill here about the fees read it
but I don't uh and I see we got an
independent auditor
and I'm not sure but I just how are we
collecting the sales tax and how do we
make sure that every can of paint H is
uh accounted for and and properly taxed
so I'm I'm not going to refer to it as a
sales tax I'm going to refer to it
because s because the sales tax implies
that uh it can be used for many purposes
in this case it is a sear charge put on
paint specifically and only for the
recycling of paint so at the point of
sale the retailers would be collecting
the funds and they would turn it over to
whatever system is set up for the
collection of those funds and again uh
Mr chair definitely uh a good question
and I would ask you to ask it to the
American codings Association
representative um but the whole
structure of the collection of the SE
charges is a constrained
overseen well documented
transparent
process uh I'm sure it is in states that
have a sales tax but for New Hampshire
we're now asking every sale uh
every you know Home Depot to have a
field on their system to collect that
tax when when the person makes a
purchase let alone what are we going to
do about people who buy it off of Amazon
so these are the questions that I will
have and hopefully you can respond to
that so the I I again I'll I'll turn
this over to um Miss mlli but I did see
that within the body of the within the
program it's the retailer can either
break it out um as an independent charge
or roll it into the overall cost so
however
but um I I would ask that you um discuss
the retail collection uh
piece with her well that will be I'm
sure you will that would be my my only
problem only only issue with it the fact
volunteer to collect it that's great you
good I love volunteer but the the
collection of the of the taxes whatever
oh excuse me the user fee please use the
right
term it is what it is okay okay
representative bur thanks for taking my
question might this be more um um what's
the word might it be better to
characterize this not as a sales tax but
as a fee for service well that's exactly
what it is it's exactly what it is and
that's why I said when you talk about
taxes those taxes are generally used for
many other purposes this is a fee for
the for the um for the collection and
recyc cycling of the product and you
know I obviously I knew that this was
going to come up and um I think from a
fiscal standpoint it really makes great
sense for us to be recycling Commodities
that otherwise towns and all of us are
having to pay for to get rid of them and
um you know it just doesn't make sense
to be tossing into landfills and paying
the Tipping fees things that we could
otherwise be reusing um I just think
that's kind of a yane thing to do right
followup well you've already had a
couple questions so let me have some
there's a followup I know but she hasn't
had a question yet
okay well thank you thank you very much
representative burrows for letting me
ask a question ahead of you thank you
for taking my question you know
obviously it's a good idea but I am
looking through the bill and I have a
couple of question questions about the
fees the tax on the
sale um is one fee there's an
administrative fee for um collecting and
then there's an additional part-time
environmentalist that will need to be
hired which will probably go to fulltime
as the program gets running so how much
more is my gallon of paint going to cost
and paint is so expensive as it is is
this going to really be a hardship for
people that want to buy uh paint and do
the right thing um well first of all
just as far as the fee for service I
like that term is concerned um it's
charged at the point of sale I I think
the administrative fee that you're that
you're talking about are you talking
about
Dees because thing is it's page four um
line
31 they'll collectively pay the
Department's Administration
administrative fee it's the yeah it's
the agency so basically let's say um
over the course of the program um I
don't know let's just say $100,000 is
collected within the paint fund um and
then
Dees will figure out what it costs to
administer the program and then let's
say I don't know we we talked about this
quite a bit they don't think it's
actually going to cost that much but
let's just say
$2500 then is
transferred as the administrative cost
to Dees so there's no additional money
being spent it's all coming out of the
One Fund which is the the
$100,000 so that administrate there's no
additional administrative fee and I
would ask that you um discuss the issue
of personnel with um with director
whimet who I think is here after seeing
the fiscal note I had some question as
to whether they actually were going to
need to hire somebody to do this and he
thought because the responsibilities of
the department Department were minimal
that it could be absorbed into the
department but either way the way this
is set up um the administrative costs
whatever they are for the department
will be fully defrayed and one of the
things we also talked about in detail
because I wanted to make sure that the
that the cost to the department uh
weren't only paid once the program was
up and running I wanted to make sure
that the costs for the Department in the
runup to the development of the program
were also re um were were paid for and
so that's been built into the bill so
it's from Soup To Nuts the and just sort
of recognizing what the revenue
situation is in the state of New
Hampshire it was really important to
make sure that Dees is Administrative
costs were covered but again the direct
answer to your question is the only fee
is the fee on the paint and that is
circumscribed by the terms of the
statute to a to a limited
amount right so the that helps the
simple answer to the question is on page
two line 2728 so if you're buying half
pint or one gallon it's going to be
$1.75 Max a gallon but if you buy a uh
anything from a two gallon or larger uh
you're going to pay $3 per
gallon okay now representative bur you
may ask another question um
representative thanks for taking my
question has there been any cost benefit
analysis to this service fee versus what
it would be the cost to clean this stuff
all up out of our out of our environment
if it were just to be dumped um I'm not
aware of one but I think it's kind of an
obvious point that it can be um
that it can it can contaminate
groundwater if it's not handled properly
I mean I don't think there's a lot of us
that are out there dumping our cans of
paint but I mean you just don't know
with with bigger users they don't know
what to do with it they I
mean they might just want to put it in a
forest somewhere and forget about it so
it I mean it it can happen um and I know
there's again there's someone here from
Dees and there's also some someone here
from the American codings Association
that can maybe answer more details with
that oh we have more questions
representative miles thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um I just want to make sure I'm
clear so there would be no option for a
retailer or a consumer to opt in
volunteer this fee it would just simply
go through as a blanket a blanket tax
for all retailers and all consumers
um in order to make the program work
that's the way the um the fee is is uh
treated yes okay thank you yeah ju uh
just a little side um I once we have a
summer home in Rhode Island and we went
in to buy a
mattress and Rhode Island has a mattress
fee charge do we have one of those here
in New Hampshire we don't but it's a
it's you know the thing is with
mattresses I mean we can go down a
rabbit hole on mattresses you answered
my question you're almost can I just I
just need to say I'm sorry I'm just
going to say it when you when you
license landfills they are licensed
based on volume and to tell you the
truth and there are people here that can
talk about it the issue of mattresses is
huge uh because they occupy massive
amounts of space in the landfill that
again could be used for better purposes
and so actually the mattress programs
are very popular I mean I don't know
have you ever disposed of a mattress you
got to yourself pay 20 or 30 bucks to
get rid of it right but that's that's at
the and you have to have a when I get
rid of it they I My Town charges me to
take that mattress right yeah so there's
feed not up front but up back all right
well thank you very much thank you the
chair call on Judy Aon who is also a
co-sponsor of the
bill good morning Mr chair and members
of the Commerce Committee for the record
my name is representative Judy Aaron I
represent the towns of aworth Goan
langon lemster and Washington in
Sullivan District
4 I'm here today to support HB
541 establishing a paint product
stewardship program I am chairman of the
house environment and agriculture
committee I'm also a member of the solid
waste working group representing the
house in that body we've worked on this
bill for for at least the past two years
or more and it's ready to be passed
through working with the solid waste
working group the Department of
Environmental Services paint
manufacturers paint stewardship program
operators and other stakeholders I
believe this bill will benefit our state
greatly why should we pass this bill
what problems does it seek to address
and solve first and foremost it is a
bill that creates a solution ution to
keeping toxic paint waste out of our
landfills which is important because
that unused paint buried in landfills
will eventually become part of the toxic
leachate in our
landfills when people have unused paint
what do they normally do with it if they
don't store it for future use they are
told to mix it with kitty litter and let
it dry out and then just toss it in the
trash that's how it gets into our
landfills the other problem that this
bill seeks to solve by creating a
mechanism to recycle paint is that we
are saving our municipalities and our
taxpayers money because all that dried
paint mixed with kitty litter is heavy
and adds weight to the refu being
trucked from our municipalities transfer
stations to our landfill
facilities recycling makes a lot more
sense than continuing to dump paint into
our
landfills paint stewardship programs
work and by establishing collection
points they are easy for our consumers
to use once you're done with your paint
project you can take any remaining paint
and simply drop it off at a place where
it can be sent to be
recycled you might even be able to
purchase that less expensive recycled
paint to use for painting a shed or for
some other project where you may not
care what the color is more importantly
our paint manufacturers support this
program because because they also want
to make sure that their product doesn't
end up polluting our landfills and
harming the
environment as for consumers I've talked
to people who have said that they would
welcome paying just a little bit more
for the paint in order to not to have to
worry how to dispose of their leftovers
and to know that dealing with paint
that's left over won't be a problem in
their transfer stations or end up
polluting the
environment and for
people who consider the modest extra
cost of a gallon of paint to be a paint
tax I would just say that a tax could
either be paid towards an incredibly
sensible recycling program or paid to
the municipality and trucking fees to
bring the dried leftover paint to
landfills to become toxic leech eight
which will later cost the taxpayer much
more money to deal with the program
outlined in this bill just makes a lot
of sense and it's a win for
manufacturers consumers municipalities
and for the environment we put a lot of
thought into the all the pieces of this
program and this program has operated
very successfully in other states it's
just a win-win all around and I truly
hope that you will support this bill and
help pass it out of the house just like
it was passed the last time thank
you uh we do have have a question
representative
post um my question is when they have
the paint they mix it all together put
it in a big barrel or whatever it is do
they clean out the
cans so as far as I understand and I
guess you know the American coding
Association can and also people from
paint cares can clarify but as I
understand paint is collected um they
might put similar white paints together
and commingle that similar red paints
together commingle that and this you
know come up with General colors uh for
paint that can't be recycled they may
send it to a waste to energy plant to be
burned and used to create energy so
there's several different ways that this
paint is recycled the cans are recycled
as well and that's how I understand that
the recycling part of it works so so
they do clean it as far as I understand
so then if they clean it are they using
solutions to prevent it to go going into
you know down the drain or when you when
you say clean it do you mean like they
strain the paint or I'm not quite sure
we will we'll have the American coding
yeah I'm not quite sure they will
explain that process how she
handles empty cans
yeah okay any other questions see none
thank you very much thank you and I
appreciate you here heing this bill no
problem uh representative
Bixby good morning committee members um
for the record uh representative Peter
Bixby from do straford 13 and ranking
member of environment and agriculture uh
and our committee has heard this bill
several times in the last decade decade
and a half uh and uh the when we had it
last year we had the most enthusiasm for
this bill in our committee that I have
ever seen uh ranging from our most
conservative members to our most you
know liberal members everyone said this
is a really good idea it is stupid to
just throw paint into a landfill uh and
there are much better ways of dealing
with it uh
so uh it is not surprising that it came
out of our committee unanimously uh
ought to pass with Amendment the am uh
the amendment that we produced was based
on the uh the Vermont uh paint care uh
program that has been running for a
number of years and when the bill came
to the body on the other side of the
wall uh the um the uh codings industry
pointed out several issues that
uh in having observed these bills uh in
different country different states
around the country they over the last um
couple decades they have seen what
really works what doesn't work quite as
well they noted a few things in the
Vermont model that weren't uh really as
well suited for Massachusetts they
suggested that perhaps we wanted to
interim study it so that we could come
up with an amendment that uh was uh
really tailored exactly to New
Hampshire's needs and Drew on all the
experience from from the other states so
uh the coding industry worked with a
number of stakeholders a number of
Representatives uh with the es with the
solid waste working group over the past
uh since last spring in order to come up
with this piece of legislation you see
before you which uh is really tailored
towards what we need in New Hampshire
now uh so uh I think that I was
disappointed it didn't go all the way
through last year but I think that what
we have in front of us is actually an
improved version over the good version
we had last year so I would on that
basis I I'd really urge you to uh carry
through on the good work and um and and
pass this i' just want to make uh there
was some question about um the relative
costs of the uh fees that are charged to
uh at the purchase point for the paint
versus what the end costs are uh
representative Aaron very well described
what happens with latex paint in ter uh
in in disposal now which is that uh in
order to be willing to take it waste
holler uh the the waste hollers want
that to be filled with kitty litter or
sand so that it is no longer liquid but
is solid so it doesn't spill on the
highway when they're driving it to the
landfill uh which I it's reasonable to
they're concerned that it not spill uh
but that does add a lot of weight and
that weight is reflected in the Tipping
fees which are reflected in your
contracts with wa with waste hollers at
the municipal level so that is that goes
onto your property tax another thing
that goes onto your property tax at even
an even higher rate is the non-latex
paint paint oilbased
paints uh are classified as Sol as
hazardous waste in the State uh because
of the Sol that they have in them and
when you're disposing of hazardous
weights the disposal rates are way
higher than tipping fees and that also
goes onto your M Municipal tax bill so
what one thing that this bill does is it
redefines for the purpose of
recycling the uh the um the oilbased
paints as non-hazardous
waste through the part of the process
where uh it would have to you know clear
the the various regulatory barriers to
get to the recycling plant uh so by
redefining it as as non-hazardous waste
I I think there's another specific term
that someone from Dees could probably
correct me on but that's the general
idea by re by reclassifying it it means
that the disposal of it is a lot less
expensive in fact because it's now in a
recycling program the cost of disposing
of it is that 75 to .75 you pay uh at
the um at the retailer and we have on
our committee last year we had one
member who does an awful lot of painting
in in in one of his uh you know other
other professions when he's not working
here at the legislature and he said that
the suggested uh fees for the program
were really cheap a really cheap way to
deal with the um cost of and headache of
having to deal with leftover
paint so I'm willing to take any
questions guess for question doubt thank
you thank you uh chair we'll Now call in
Heidi mlli who represents the American
codings Association
and in support of the
Bill thank you Mr chair
so my name
is Heidi mcalli I'm the senior vice
president of government Affairs for the
American codings Association the codings
Association is the Premier trade
Association for paint manufacturers and
the raw material
suppliers 95% of the paint that is
manufactured in this country is made by
companies that are members of our trade
Association and one of the Hallmarks uh
of this program that we're talking about
today is that our association came
together in the early 2000s with um
environmental agencies across the
country um environmental groups across
the country um the product stewardship
Institute to sort of develop the
framework for this program um after
several years of conversations um on how
best to deal with the issue of leftover
paint we came up with this solution
solution uh this framework solution and
we made a commitment that the industry
would move forward to try to implement
this program as a test and we started
that test in the state of Oregon we
passed this law basically in the state
of Oregon as a two-year pilot and um at
the end of two years promised to
re-evaluate it if it was successful we
would move forward with a permanent
program that was in 2008 that program's
been operating successfully ever since
and in the meantime we have passed this
law and implemented programs in 11 other
states we are currently working on two
other states at the moment that will
come online and launch programs in
2025 um really thrilled to hear the
testimony of Representative eel um
representative Aaron and representative
Bixby um to talk about the the
stakeholder
base and group that has come to De
together to support this program and
help us develop the program for the
State of New Hampshire I'm not sure that
I've ever uh testified in front of other
states with quite that broad base of
support um and quite and quite frankly
the assistance in developing the
language for this program I think what
you're looking at really is the
state-ofthe-art for a stewardship
program for a liquid formulated product
so um I would like to tell you how this
program works just a broad overview it
is um once we pass this law it is
incumbent upon the stewardship
organization called Paint care which is
a organization the American codings
Association created to run this
program they will develop a program plan
for the State of New Hampshire working
closely with Dees they will develop
the entire program and submit that to
Dees for its review and approval what
the program plan will include is our
plan how we're going
to um develop the collection
locations how we're going to work with
the haulers the
Transporters and how we're going to work
with processors to manage the end of
life of this material so we will go out
our staff will go out and talk to all of
the different retail locations as well
as all of your Municipal uh facilities
that are currently doing household
hazardous waste
collection ask them to participate on a
voluntary basis with us as collection
locations our goal is to make it as
convenient as possible for your
residents to bring back paint that they
no longer want um we right now we are
working with over 2,000 retailers across
the country in those 11 states that I've
already mentioned mentioned we will then
contract with haulers and Transporters
they're all hazardous waste uh certified
haulers and Transporters that will go to
those collection sites pick up all of
the postc consumer paint material take
it to a processor at that processing
facility decisions will be made about
latex paint and about solvent-based
paint latex paint can be recycled paint
into paint and paint sometimes into
other types of products like cement um
or you know sidewalk blocks and things
of that
nature the solvent-based paint typically
cannot be recycled there just isn't the
technology available um it I will say
it's an emerging technology there is one
company that we know of in Canada that
is currently taking solvent-based paint
and recycling it back into paint but for
the most part that technology isn't
widely available there isn't really the
capacity to handle as much as we
collect but our goal is to pick up all
of that postc consumer paint latex and
solvent and divert it from the landfills
we take it to the processor like I said
where those decisions are made with
regard to the latex paint we are
recycling approximately 75 to 80% of
that product and diverting it from the
landfill
there is a certain percentage of that
latex paint that has been frozen and
thawed so many times or it's otherwise
contaminated that we may not be able to
do anything with so some of that
eventually will go to a landfill but
it's a a it's a very small amount the
solvent-based paint is then is sent for
Waste to energy recovery so we can
extract the energy uh from the solvents
in those products
so that's the
overall structure of of how the program
from the consumer side when a
consumer comes into a paint store and
wants to return their paint it's a
pretty painless process they bring their
paint into a collection location give it
to a customer service agent and
hopefully they shop around and buy some
other products there's no charge when
they drop it off it is completely free
of charge the only fee involved to a
consumer is when a consumer purchases a
new can of paint and at that point in
time there is a we call it an assessment
I like the fee for service um uh phrase
but there is a fee for service that is
added to the cost of that
paint the cost of paint right now ranges
anywhere from between $20 to $100 a
gallon
typically the cost for a 1gallon can in
our program programs ac across the
country averages about 75 cents I don't
know what it will be for the State of
New Hampshire that is something that
we'll evaluate once this program is is
adopted into
law and I do want to talk about that
process for just a
moment 100% of the revenue that funds
this activity is that fee for service so
every time a can of paint is purchased
that fee goes directly to Pain Care and
here's how the cash flow really
works once we're working in New
Hampshire we're going to talk to every
single
manufacturer that sells paint in this
state that fee for service is assessed
on every single can of paint whether
it's a Sherman Williams a bear paint or
any any other brand of paint it's
Universal if it's an architectural paint
it's going to get this
fee manufacturers will submit that fee
they will figure out what their sales
are in the state of New Hampshire
multiply it times the fee and send a
check directly to paint care the
manufacturer then includes that fee on
the price of the paint that they are
sending to Distributors and retailers
retailers when they sell the paint to a
consumer gets that 75 cents or whatever
the fee is when they sell the paint so
it it's a very seamless operation in
terms of the cash flow for this for this
program on the expense Side Of The
Ledger we will go out and talk to
Transporters will issue uh um an RFP to
the Transporters in the state and the
processors ask them to submit bids to
work with us um once we figure out what
the sales are in the state of New
Hampshire and we figure out what the
cost for transportation and processing
and other administrative you know
typical business type costs like
insurance and salaries and things we can
then figure out what our budget is and
then really determine what the schedule
of fees should be it's a smaller fee for
a smaller can larger fee for a larger
can but like I said
typically on average a one gallon can
typically the fee for service is about
cents so that's how the the um the
budget process works we are really proud
of this program um we try very hard to
make this a zeroc cost program so we
will be working very closely with Dees
as our oversight agency and we will pay
them for their time to administer this
program we will not only pay them for
their time reviewing our program plan
reviewing our annual report and any
enforcement activity that they believe
is necessary we'll pay them an
administrative fee to submit our plan at
the very beginning of this process so um
as I said our goal is to make this a a
zero cost program for the State of New
Hampshire
um I guess a couple of other points I
would just like to make um and I hope
I'm not running out of time I don't mean
to go over
um once this program launches um on day
one retailers will begin processing that
fee for service on a can of paint on day
one you can empty your basement or
garage doesn't matter how old that paint
is all of that Legacy paint we want out
of your basement and garage you know we
want to be able to divert it from the
landfill and recycle as much as possible
so all that Legacy paint comes in there
were a couple questions about the
containers paint being a liquid
formulated product we can't collect it
unless it's in container so we
absolutely take the containers paint
cans you know sometimes they're all
plastic sometimes they're all metal
sometimes they're hybrid um our goal is
to recycle the containers as much as we
possibly can that really depends upon
capacity in the region for Plastics
Recycling and metal recycling we do
better with the metal cans obviously
it's a higher value uh recycling
activity um we struggle a little bit
with the plastic side of it but we're
getting better and better but our our
intent and our goal is to recycle those
plastic containers as much as
possible and the question about do we
clean them out um we
don't we will work with the container
recyclers whatever their process is we
do our best to work with them so I'm not
aware that we're doing that in any state
actually cleaning the containers
themselves that's something the the
processors and the recyclers are doing
um but whatever that cost is it's added
into our
process
and if I could just one other thing I
wanted to describe before I I end there
we do have a program called a large
volume pickup so our retail collections
in our Municipal facilities that we're
working with they're designed for
residents so you know I don't know about
all of you but I have about eight cans
in my garage right now and when Marilyn
gets their program up and running I
can't wait to get
there but commercial entities small
businesses sometimes collect large
volumes of um leftover paint so we do
have this program and we don't want them
you know loading up their car with a 100
cans and bringing it to a retailer
you're going to overwhelm any retailer
you go to with that kind of volume so in
order to service those small business
businesses we've developed this program
that will send a transporter directly to
that commercial business pick up all of
that paint and take it directly to a
processor that's included no extra
charge we actually have regular
customers that can just call us up and
say okay I've I've got my 100 gallons
come and get it they don't have to move
it we send the transporter there who
moves it themselves so it it's working
beautifully and it's a real Boon to
small small businesses and you know
hotels schools prisons um painting
contractors lots of small businesses
utilize this program so I think with
that I'm happy to take any questions
representa
spear thank you excuse me you mentioned
that certain types of paint or in are
going to be end up uh being burned what
kind of chemicals come out of that I
mean we are we careful about pollution
or air pollution or anything like that
what kind of chemicals we sld from that
there um I don't know a lot about that
process but all of the the facilities
that specialize in waste to energy
combustion um are you know are fully C
certified I mean we make a commitment
that our endof life management for paint
products is going to be environmentally
sound and we ensure that all of our
processors are um
you know in compliance with
environmental regulations federal and
state so I'm happy to look into that a
little bit further for you but it's a
pretty common process I I would like to
follow on that with just one comment we
have a a plant in um Manchester that
burns waste and it's turning out to be
quite the problem so I'm very concerned
about what kind of chemicals are coming
out of this would you believe uh would
you believe yeah representative
BRS thank you and thank you for taking
my question um I was curious about the
program in Oregon and I'm wondering if
there was any data in terms of the
return on investment of the program
versus the costs of cleaning up all this
stuff if it goes into a
landfill there actually
are um are you familiar with the product
stewardship Institute
okay um the product stewardship
Institute is a thirdparty organization
um that that
[Music]
um endorses extended producer
responsibility programs they're very
engaged in lots of different consumer
Commodities and have been for
years um they have done some studies of
our programs um I believe the Oregon
program the Connecticut program and our
Colorado program
um I'm not sure that they specifically
follow a strict cost benefit analysis
but um they have been you know studies
Implement case studies on our program
after the program's been in operation
for a certain number of years and I'm
happy to share those with you um in
terms of cost benefit analysis one thing
I I would I would say is one of the big
benefits for the state and for your you
your local government entities that run
the household hazardous waste facilities
and I know um representative eel did a
good job describing this but just to
emphasize when we partner with them we
basically pay for all the costs related
to
paint end of life
management so we will pay for the
transportation and processing of all of
the paint That's collected at that those
local facilities um so that really frees
up part of their budget to spend on
other program priorities um it it's a
very significant benefit for the local
uh government
entities represent
sesa thanks for taking a question um it
seems like a very wonderful program I
see that based on the chart that this
program started in 2010 in Oregon but in
last 14 years I see only 13 states have
signed up so far so what is the main
push back from majority majority of the
states what I'm sorry your question is
what are the challenges what is the main
push back from majority of States why
only 13 State have signed up so far in
years um well part of it I I will say
part of it is um resources um I'm I'm
only one person I'm basically the the
government Affairs person that's pushing
this in different states across the
country and any given moment we have
bills in five other states uh to move
forward with this um some states work
more quickly than others um
unfortunately I've been working in
Massachusetts for probably eight or nine
years and I still haven't um been able
to move forward with it um we passed the
bill in Colorado in one year
um but other states you know have taken
some time uh to get the bill across the
the Finish Line it it's really an
education issue it it probably takes um
a fair amount of time to do some
education for decision makers working
with the agency developing the the
stakeholder group um in some states even
where we have no opposition whatsoever
it takes us several years um in in aate
state where there there's some
opposition it takes us a while to
educate that opposition group on the
benefits and try to answer all their
questions um follow up quick followup
further question yeah so my question is
what is the what what are some of the
main concerns those states have shown to
you who have done opposition so far in
14 years what are the main concern they
have shared with you I I mean I the
biggest you know I'm not what is the
biggest concern perhaps the the biggest
question is really the issue of the fee
it's understanding how the fee works and
trusting um the industry to do this job
the way we say we're going to do it um
but you know we have now almost 15 years
of history and we have 11 states with
data to show you our our website is
completely transparent you can see the
financials for every single state that
we're working and right now if you go to
my website
um so you know at the beginning when we
were trying to to move this this process
or this program across the states nobody
had heard of epr an extended producer
responsibility was new it it's not new
any longer it's it's much more
mainstream there are lots of programs
out there the concepts are much better
understood thank you okay let me let's
cut to the chase all right I'm trying to
follow the bouncing ball here here okay
cuz you T first you said the
manufacturers are reporting
to the state
yes and they're collecting a they are
passing the fee on at that
time because then it sounded like you
were doing it was a value added tax
because then because the the fee is
actually collected at point of
sale but I wasn't sure what the Manu
facturers are reporting are they not are
they they're reporting how where how
much paint they're making and where it
went
yes are but they're not writing a check
at the time the the money doesn't come
until it's assessed at the point of
purchase and then who sends the money
to to you or the state I was a little
fuzzy on that too so the the
that man at the beginning of this
program in every single year
manufacturers estimate what their sales
are in the state of New Hampshire at the
very beginning they're going to cut a
check send it directly to paint care so
before any paint is sold they've already
invested in this
program um otherwise we would have no
money to operate so they've sent the
money to paint
care then they sell the paint in the
state of New
Hampshire and they add that fee to the
retailers or to Distributors and
retailers
retailers obviously they're paying for
the paint that they're selling so
they're paying that fee the retailers
are but the retailers recoup their money
when they sell the paint to
Consumers typically that's 75 cents
that's they re coup you're getting paid
so that retailers are not doing any
reporting they're not paying anybody
other than they're buying the paint so
it's built into the wholesale price to
them correct ah so here's the solution
to the problem we actually do this in
New Hampshire and it's called the beer
tax the beer tax the consumer has no
idea that it exists as a matter of fact
even the retail ER doesn't even know it
exists it's collected at the
distribution
level and right at this moment because
I'm looking at the beer tax collector is
actually just enter the room because
we're going to be executing a bill but I
going to say at this moment that if
we're going to deal with the number one
problem the push back is that the cost
of this fee for this service is got got
to be built into the wholesale price
before the product arrives in New
Hampshire just just an idea we'll talk
further but I just want you to know
that's where I personally would be
trying to take this bill but I is that
different than what I described well in
the sense that that the consumer is
going to be is paying the the whole
value at the time the
purchase okay that's a sales tax okay
call it what it is that's a sales tax
okay but when a tax is collected at the
wholesale or distributor
level okay yes we do call it a tax but
it's unbeknownst to the consumer it has
nothing to do with the consumer and it
has nothing to do with what the margin
the retailer decides to sell the product
for and what the consumer is paying
and that's where the consumer is
shopping around now you might argue the
downside of this is is that you're going
to end up they're going to pass on the
full cost in the when it comes time to
sell it and the and the consumer says oh
look that gallon of paint is
a175 more in New Hampshire than when I
can pay for it in Massachusetts because
they didn't pass the
law that might be the downside yet not
yet that's what I that's but I'm saying
is what if we were going to do something
like this the model we have here in New
Hampshire is our beer tax model which is
built around the distributor collecting
the tax the tax is is is the fee is
collected ahead just like you're already
saying they're going to estimate their
fee okay but in this case we don't even
want to estimate we want every time they
ship we want them to send the fee the
fee and it's based on gallonage Purely
gallonage we don't care what the size of
the container is we're not even worried
about the size it's based on gallonage
that's a model we have here in New
Hampshire something to think about okay
would you believe would you believe
excuse me okay representative
solivan would you would you believe Mr
chairman I've been sitting here thinking
the same thing you just said for the
most of this this presentation right
guess you you're familiar with it okay
represent macul thank it it it seems to
me and correct if I'm wrong but the
model that you suggested is exactly what
chairman Hutt is saying because it's
it's actually paid by the manufacture
then it's passed on to the wholesaler
and then it's passed on to the retailer
but I think it's exactly the same thing
as the way you're doing the beer tax
unless I misunderstood what you said I I
I have to feain ignorance about your
beer beer tax so it's hard for me to say
that's exactly it but it sounds very
similar to what we want to accomplish I
you know in other states we have had
this conversation of should the fee
be um itemized on a receipt or an
invoice there you go and um and it's
interesting that conversation goes both
ways some states want it on the invoice
other states don't want it on the
invoice typically we at ACA and paint
care have never really taken a position
on that I mean our
the fee has to be
Universal it has to be the same fee on
every single brand of paint it has to be
collected retailers cannot have the
option of assessing it or not assessing
it it has to be there otherwise the
program you know financially won't be
sound um there are some consumer
protection laws that we're running into
um right now that are
requiring additional information about
any fees added on to Consumer products
that's an issue we've been dealing with
just in the last year or
so um
okay representative G thank you thank
you for taking my question on page five
lines 7 through n you're changing the
designation from hazardous waste to
Universal waste can we talk about that
please um yes so
in order to provide the full range of
services we want to be able to collect
solvent-based paint and latex paint
which is oilbased the latex paint
typically is not hazardous the
solvent-based paint is it's typically
flammable
um all of our haulers are you know have
a hazardous waste uh certification so
that's not really an issue for them but
for the retail locations to collect that
type of um material and hang on to it
until we can get a transporter there
there are some issues um Universal waste
is a way to manage
lowrisk um uh waste products it's a
pretty well accepted Concept in
hazardous waste management um we
actually have a petition pending with
EPA to designate all paint waste as a
Universal waste and and this helps us um
sort of streamline some of the processes
um that we have to um engage in to
collect the solvent based
paint thank you very
much you okay uh Mike winstat from
Hampshire Dees
morning Mr chair members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Mike whimet I serve as the Director of
the waste management division for the
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services I'm joined this
morning by Mike knor who heads up our
material he tricked me he was I was
gonna be yeah I didn't quite actually
I'm joined by Todd pisit who heads up
our haard space management Bureau and I
think we we switched a little because we
knew there was going to be a question
about hazardous way so Todd's going to
be here to help with that um the
department is not taking a position on
this bill um however we thought it would
be helpful to we always try to share
with any committee any uh thoughts we
have about a bill like this even though
we may not be taking a position and to
give a little context in history um as
uh the sponsor indicated this is a bill
that has been around for more than 10
years um this concept um we so we worked
on it off and on in a number of
legislative sessions um I think that uh
at the time we first started talking
about it it was a nent program in other
states and there was some discomfort
about whether we really could understand
how it was going to work and whether it
would work for New Hampshire um so it
has gone through a number of iterations
but I think the the overall program and
certainly the paint CARE program that uh
Miss mcalli described to you um has
really matured and and evolved over that
time um we uh
uh we did indeed as the sponsor
indicated work very closely with the
sponsors and with the folks from the ACA
to uh address concerns that we had about
the original drafts of this uh
legislation and and many of those
concerns were were able to be really
addressed through that process so it was
a very collaborative and productive
process for doing so um I will say that
uh this bill and the concept of a paint
uh stewardship program and this is at
its heart this isn't a product
stewardship program it's really about
the manufacturers taking responsibility
for not just the production and sale of
their materials but also dealing with it
on the tail end when there's a disposal
sounds like past to me right exactly so
um so I will say that this uh this kind
of a program is very consistent with um
the statutory Provisions in RSA 149 M
the solid waste management act based on
trying to have respon responsible
management of all wastes and ensuring
that we recycle whenever we can versus
sending for disposal it's also
consistent with the goals of the solid
waste management plan which um you know
further puts more meat on the bones on
that that we worked very hard on and
published a couple of years ago and it
was definitely an area that we
identified for work so it's very
consistent with the the work plan that
we've set out over the next several
years the other thing I would raise and
then we can we' be happy to go to
questions um is that and I'm not sure
it's it's been touched on a little bit
here but there's really a public health
and safety component to this as well
because we know and I know my own
personal experience that um if you're a
homeowner and you're doing maintenance
and such and you you can end up
accumulating pretty significant amount
of both latex and and and and
solvent-based paints and Coatings in
your home and most people uh because
they don't want to put it out in the
garage or in the shed because they can't
they don't want it to freeze they keep
it in their basement and so all of those
things slowly over time if you have a
can of paint and a few years later you
go to it and it's a hockey puck there's
a reason for that all the solvents and
material and and volatile substances in
that have leaked out into your home and
you've been breathing them so um that's
not a great thing obviously and in many
cases people keep those because they
don't really have a place to bring they
don't they they know that they you know
it's it's not that convenient to try to
bring it out and spread it with K if
it's latex paint mix it with kitty
litter and dispose of it and if it's
solvent-based paint really the only
appropriate option is to bring it to a
household collection day which in most
towns if they have them at all or only
once a year and you've got a time it and
make sure you've got it on your calendar
and you get it there and then I will
note that when we've talked to towns we
do provide grants to towns matching
grants for holding household collection
days for for household hazardous waste
the towns will tell you that the line
share of the cost that they incur with
their contractors for those collection
days are tied to paint products um they
don't even take the latex paints but the
solvent-based paints end up being on a
per gallon basis famously expensive
because they you know they've got a hire
a Houser space contractor who's got a
chemist on site and they're overpacking
each individual container it's a very
inefficient and expensive way to do it
and what I've also heard from folks who
operate landfills or transfer stations
is that the most uh uh high volume day
for disposal of paint products at a
landfill is the Monday after a household
collection day happened because somebody
had a soccer game or they forgot about
it on their calendar and they didn't get
there and so now they've been they get
mad because they've waited a year for
the collection day and they missed it so
they just bring it all to the landfill
so it's not a great system and you know
something like this is going to be
potentially uh providing a much better
more costeffective way of dealing with
these materials so with that um I will
uh we'll go to
questions okay yeah represent
hen how come you're
neutral that is a fair question and to
be very candid um we we're we're
basically not taking positions really on
any bills right now because we've just
haven't been able to get um it's quality
time with the governor's office to to
outline where the policy positions on
bills are going to be so across the
board that's what we've been doing we
expect that will change in future but
for now that's that's where we're
at great thank you very much
Cher will Callin Reagan
Binet from
Northeast uh re resource recovery
Association oh this is where I get my
blue
bags morning you have to push the good
morning you
good yes thank you I'm Reagan biset I'm
with the Northeast resource recovery
Association we are a Cooperative style
recycling nonprofit and we work with 90%
of the communities in New Hampshire um
who are members of our organization so
our mission is to make sure that we can
have Municipal recycling programs be
both environmentally sustainable but
also environmentally s uh financially
sustainable and environmentally uh
responsible so our organization as a
general policy doesn't take positions on
legislation but I am here to just
provide some information that I thought
would be useful to the committee as you
consider this
bill um I'll also add that I serve on
the solid waste working group as a
representative for the Northeast
resource recovery
Association so our organization Among
The Cooperative programs that we offer
for our Municipal members we offer
household hazardous uh waste collection
days we work with a reputable vendor who
uh manages and recycles
waste that is collected at these Town
program events and I have some data I
can share with you about the cost that
municipalities uh incur related to paint
collection so we looked at data from uh
recent years for over a dozen
communities for which we've worked uh to
help them manage their household
hazardous waste collection days the
average population of these communities
that we looked at was 9,600 people
and the average cost of their collection
Day event was about
$113,000 a little over half of all of
the items collected by weight which is
how they pay for the cost of the event a
little over half of what they collected
was paint so what that means is that for
these communities that we looked at on
average they spent uh about
$7,100 for the collection and recycling
of paint for their community
um and as you heard uh often communities
will only offer these events once a year
or maybe even once every two years to
their residents because of the
significant cost to municipalities to
offer these programs and therefore uh
you know you could see that how a bill
like this would offer more opportunities
for residents to be able to access free
Recycling and and management of their
paint without having to wait for a once
a year event um and this bill does seem
like it would provide opportunities to
help mitigate some of the costs that
municipalities are currently incurring
in order to recycle
paint so thank you thank
you thank you very much I have three
cards left they're all in
support pretty obvious why uh so all I
ask is you guys be
brief okay so the first one on my pile
is Mark Mor
Moro Moro from
cassella
so good morning I'll I'll be brief okay
um
thank you for the opportunity to provide
testimony um to the committee
and chairman hunt for House Bill 451 my
name is Mark Morgan and my testimony is
in support of House Bill
451 I am a landfill manager for cassella
Waste
Systems um I've worked in the waste
industry in various capacities for
several several years here in New
Hampshire cassella is a publicly traded
Regional vertically integrated Solid
Waste Service Company we provide
Resource Management expertise services
to residential commercial Municipal
institutional and Industrial
customers focus in the areas of solid
waste collection disposal transfer
Recycling and Organics
management product stewardship programs
such as that that's proposed by House
Bill 451 help to manage problematic
materials in the waist streams and I
don't need to get into the particulars
about that I think you've heard enough
about that but paint is one of those
difficult to manage
materials in addition to paint some
other examples that have been mentioned
earlier um included in some of these uh
product stewardship programs include
items like textiles
mattresses uh carpets film Plastics
flexible packaging tires solar panels
wind turbines batteries and appliances
stewardship programs like this promote
and create a safe and meaningful process
in which everyone involved in the life
cycle of a particular product has
responsibility for endof Life management
of that product that otherwise may be
cumbersome difficult or unsafe to
process for these reasons cassella
supports House Bill
451 thank you very much chair will'll
call on Henry veu was
management you know the best for speech
I ever said is
ditto yes uh I I I'll be a little longer
than ditto uh just um Waste Management
uh runs the turkey landfill uh in
Rochester we accept about a third or
manage about a third of the waste that's
generated in the State uh Waste
Management supports the bill um it's
cons consistent with uh current state
law right now back in
1996 this
legislature um passed a law that created
a solid waste management hierarchy and
the number one uh preference for dealing
with waste is Source reduction which is
don't create the waste in the first
place second is reuse and Recycling and
that's consistent with this bill um
third is
composting the there's um energy uh uh
the incineration with energy recovery um
and then it's landfilling so putting
this stuff in landfills is not the
preferred option there are other options
which the state law already directs us
to try to achieve uh to representative
Spears uh point about uh incineration in
Manchester so that incinerator is a
sewage and sludge incinerator it does
not burn uh Municipal Solid Waste um so
it's I I think it's different uh from
the go can we talk about this afterwards
I have some more questions okay but
anyways Waste Management supports the
bill um and that's it D all perfect
thank you and last but not least Nash
Grace from the Bia and I believe he did
distribute a letter I did Mr chair n gra
for the Bia we are the state why Chamber
of Commerce and the Allied manufacturing
association uh we I just want to be 100%
clear we do not support sales taxes but
we do support our business Community uh
what we're talking about here although I
know there's debate about the phrase fee
is that
manufacturers across the board and the
paint manufacturers want to raise their
prices equally across the board that's
an antitrust issue it's commonly known
as price collusion we want to make sure
there's an exception for that because
there's a good public policy reason to
allow that that Universal raise to occur
uh and that would be for the everything
you've heard over the last hour and a
half to uh to deal with paint so not a
tax it is manufacturers across the board
raising their prices equally and then
using that for a good public
purpose thank you Mr chair Mr
chair and thank you oh we do have a
question representative M thank you
thanks for taking my question when when
I was asking that question of Miss mlli
I saw you back there nodding your head
so I believe that you agree with me that
the way that they're doing this is
exactly the way we tax beer the
difference is is that we shouldn't at
the retail lever level put in the
receipt that they paid the
tax do you agree with that just to be
clear not a taxia does not support sales
taxes we do support manufacturers who
want to raise their prices equally
across the board and use that for a good
public policy purpose but is is not this
the way question you mean CL is not just
the way that chairman uh suggested that
that the way the beer Tax Works the beer
fee Works in my conversation with the uh
the paint manufacturers and their
representatives my understanding is is
this is the way that that the chairman
uh had previously described that you
would that you would allow industry to
do this again across the board not a
tax and with that I will thank you very
much and I will close the public hearing
on houseb
451 okay so NE to say we're we're a
little bit behind
here so I ask the members not to run off
um because I believe we have the
liquor liquor
subcommittee um
the
e
e e
okay all right so we'll take up first
one is uh HB
81 okay so who's who hang on I'll get
you the list
okay two
six
and
uh no no he's not on
liquor
uh
H one two three
Wan
post okay so um this was the
bill um this was your bill right wasn't
this your bill so what we did is take
out that sentence that was you know
people could read into it and just
draw through rest the rest rooms and
section this is the this is the model of
how we want to do things this just get
rid of everything that we don't need and
just move it forward okay all right so
um ought to pass on
Amendment okay move by representative
Sullivan second by representative
pusc amendment
number
0078 we're we're just at the
beginning 78 okay okay all right any
discussion on the amendment for the
members of the liquor committee
announc all those in favor say I I those
oppos you're right okay post so that's
one two three
four five five zip you put it here
yep are we executing no this is the
subcommittee sub committee we we will be
executing these uh
momentarily okay next one all right
house bill
um so House Bill 77 this amendment is as
kind of uh I handed out in the
subcommittee and in terms of how we are
going to handle this
issue that's going to have atpa
oops okay so in this case uh we took it
out uh of where it was weigh in uh under
licenses and we took it and even though
we played with the idea of the consumer
protection act but I think we got it
reaffirmed by by our consumer protection
division again yesterday to please go
lightly with anything that gets stuck in
the consumer protection act uh but this
abely made the most sense given the
enforcement is already uh in the powers
of the uh Liquor Commission so in this
case The Liquor Commission is already
there they're looking at all the toys
that uh that any retailer might have to
uh look at licenses um so it makes
perfect sense and they have all the
power of being able to research and find
out whether there's any secret files
being kept on their computer but I can
never imagine you have they've ever done
that before but they had that authority
to do that okay any questions about the
amendment all right uh I I
move okay so this is yeah this just to
pass on the
amendment I'll move it or actually P two
SEC moves it I'll
move second in by Burrows
had a question but I guess it's too late
okay you do have a question yes what is
your question and I'm sorry if I if I
didn't catch it before yes this is
strictly talking about the scanners for
the licenses for uh when we go to buy
alcohol or whatever it's not anything to
do with uh some of the other things that
actually like porn shops that actually
have to scan it exactly this is just
this is simply and and we have the added
benefit this is not only uh uh liquor
but it's also cigarettes
right right of course okay so and then
marijuana if it was
ever
if the cold the cold day in Hell In
which that
passes okay so we include you right so
shouldn't it be six to zero uh sure yes
that's
right okay all right one same all those
in favor please raise your hand one two
three four five six okay six
just the
subcommittee have this
one this is what we put
here
[Music]
okay okay me or you
you okay all right
now we can go into executive session
right 1 two three four five six
seven8 10 11 12 13 14 15 I Green Sheet
you want it you want I'm supposed to
fill it out
okay okay uh ex sub committ where EXA
what do I do with this piece of
paper okay uh before we begin the exec
session um I decided that we will not
take up House Bill 359
today not we will not do it
today because I feel like
it this is the the uh the power of the
of the power of the gav is I can decide
what bill we take up when we take it up
so
okay moving on so we first H have House
Bill
242 representative
pusc second by representative burough
who ought to pass any discussion on the
motion right on this this this goes
fast okay any discussion on the motion2
yes okay she's I'm just waiting for the
clerk when she's ready now you need a
voting sheet okay is that the one John T
no that's a different
sheet uh oh this one no r
r okay
is this what we're looking
for huh is this what we're looking
for that
usually okay
is
it you got write down the sheet right
okay that to
[Music]
majority me
another P another pile
okay
okay all right the motion is uh to pass
is any discussion on the motion seeing
none the clerk will call the role
that's you do we start with uh no you
end with me okay starts with me and with
him
puchek yes Osborne is not
here Ammon yes Cole yes post is yes
perelli yes Walsh not here miles yes
don't do that oh
just and I not voting okay not
voting she found them thank you but you
can still we'll take them okay thanks
pra yes
buros Herbert yes mclear yes spear yes
Gibbs yes Sullivan yes
jasa
yes and salvi not
here
oops two three four five six seven eight
yes Hunt is yes oh Hunt is yes I'm sorry
have to go back in the good old days I
didn't have to
vote 15 I think I'm a sponsor of the
bill
15 to Z motion passes at 15 15 to
nothing Z okay um all those in favor of
placing uh House Bill what number are we
2 242 on the consent Calendar please say
I that supposed so moved unanimously do
you put it consent Y where do you write
it uh on that sheet that that other
sheet you started with the this one
consent so you put in the uh the vote
okay the vote was 15 zip you guys and
then down here you write
consent consent yes and and then
just okay one down 35 to
go okay uh next House Bill 81 uh along
patrons to uh take purchase alcohol
beverages into the restroom or of a
restaurant um the subcommittee has just
voted on an
amendment okay so now for those of you
who did not get it we'll pass this
around just
um too stuff
okay all right so uh representative uh
pusc seconded by representative Burrows
who's who's doing this one you are am
you always used to do a look on okay
said oh yes
okay this is this was voted on by the
subcommittee so this is now we're in
exec session right now so we are uh
voting uh for a to pass on the
amendment is there any discussion of the
amendment not what is the amendment
Amendment uh that
one Amendment oh you know what I
just yeah this is it amendment number
0078 007 with an eight uh up
here
okay to yes thank you okay any
discussion on the motion
all right seeing none the clerk will
call the
role uh so that would be pusk
yes Osborne is not here yes he is he is
here me oh you came in welcome
oh are you a GU thank you Ammon yes Cole
yes post is yes pereli yes Walsh is out
miles yes
pra burough yes
Herbert Herbert yes mcclear yes yes
spear sorry yes
Gibbs yes
Sullivan terasa yes salvi not
here and yes
hunt so what is the the
vote we're voting on the amendment
should be 13 14 15 16 16 is it okay now
the motion is ought to pass 16 to Z 16
ought to pass as
amended considering is a same thing I we
have our are we moving it yes so I uh so
representative pusc second by
represented
Burrows moves ought to pass as amended
this
and okay what it B done right not yet
you got to we got to do the roll call
okay so you yeah this is to pass on the
amendment in the amendment
number Am Number
78 okay and today is 130
okay first day on the job
here okay is the motion clear ought to
pass as
amended the clerk will call the role on
us to
pass right so it is duplication but yes
okay it is a little Annoying about the
duplication to pass as amended correct
okay and Bill
is 81
okay okay and we can start yep so
um we have
pusk yes Osborne yes Ammon yes Cole yes
poost is here yes pelli yes Walsh is out
miles yes Pressa yes burough yes Herbert
yes melier yes spear yes Gibbs yes
Sullivan yes terasa yes and Sal is
out Hunt is yes Hunt is yes keep on
forgetting
that's
16 just motion pass 16 zip all those in
favor of placing on the consent Calendar
please say I I I those opposed so moved
unanimously okay next up uh prohibiting
businesses from scanning individuals
licenses when selling alcohol or tobacco
products uh representative pusk seconded
by representative burough moves on to
pass on the
amendment number uh 80 80 okay
is
this we is this 80 or is this
amend right
this I know okay just
Scrat and what is it yeah that's
right okay for later
yeah okay uh the amendment um basically
uh moves it out of of U safety puts it
into the liquor statute and this would
be something The Liquor Commission would
enforce and and what the enforcement is
is to ensure that the machines that uh
all they do is have a red red green
light bulb and cannot H store any
personal
information so a good question yes
represent shance so they are going to
guarantee that the scanner is not going
to store the information they are that
is their their guarantee so so normally
in a case like this if someone were to
be
suspicious that it's storing
information what people have been doing
is calling up the Attorney General's
office and the consumer protection
division who was here he was here
yesterday and he was saying is you know
he he's just on that call he's not going
to go in and you know to a merchant and
to find out what they're doing what
they're going what's going on so in this
case because the Liquor Commission
already has statutory authority to do
investigations on any
lensey The Liquor Commission absolutely
will know what machines they're looking
at and if and they'll know the machines
because there's only a handful of them
out there and so they'll look at the
machine and they'll know which machine
you know if the machine is what they
expect they'll already know that that
machine does not store any data that the
purpose of the machine is Simply Red Red
Light Green Light then then there won't
be a problem however if they see a
machine they've never seen before yeah
then absolutely they will do their home
homework on that machine to find out
whether that machine has the capability
of storing and if it does the uh The
Establishment runs the risk of losing
their license and there also a
discussion uh that was that right now
there's no Universal scanner per se so
did are they going to work on that yeah
they're they're
absolutely they believe it or not
they're actually seen plenty of these
machines already they already know about
these machines because they see them all
the time okay so but that it's uh the
problem was that the the bill as it was
introduced was piggybacking on a statute
that was already in lure that was
related to pawn
shops which absolutely stored the
driver's license number because that's
what the pawn shops were you know they
wanted so in that case those machines
cannot be used in a liquor establishment
okay they just they they be barred
because of the
statute any other discussion on the
motion about to pass on the
amendment okay see none the clerk would
call the RO pusk yes Osborne Ammon yes
Cole yes Leisa postes yes brelli yes
wound miles yes Pressa yes buros yes
Herbert yes Maier yes spear yes Gibbs
yes Sullivan yes jassa yes consv
not yes should be oh I put that up there
for you and yes for chairman hunt so we
are 16 okay 16 motion carry 16 zip the
uh motion now representative p t SEC
seconded by representative burough moves
uh to pass as amended is there any
discussion on the motion seeing
none the clerk will call the role next
Ro next sheet there we go and this is
when she's ready okay so we have this is
House Bill
77 amendment number
okay so pusk yes
Osborne Ammon yes Cole yes L post is
here and uh yes Porcelli yes Walsh is
out miles Pressa yes burough yes hbert
yes melier yes spear Gibbs yes solivan
chassa yes s is not here and chairman
hunt
yes okay all those in favor of placing
House Bill uh 77 on the consent Calendar
please say I I those opposed so moved
unanimously yes
okay next up is House Bill 79 establish
Hing commission to study the
privatization of the Liquor
Commission representative Tac seconded
by representative burough moves uh
inexpedient to
legislate on 276 yep that's it you got
the right6
okay this is it
276 79 oh no 799 oh this is the 79
number9 oh you you were we're on a page
number ahead of ourselves but okay just
uh hold on to that one okay this was
77 we did 77 over here we rewrote it on
here okay we we just did 77
Y and this is 77 79 I know but we see
theoretically these sheets were in
numeric order but who knows what
happened
uh see we've got 276
359 do they give you extras of
these uh executive
ones
um all these
other um
16 look you know what we're not going to
take up
359 yep and we're going to do this as
this number okay
yep and this
is what number 79 79
okay all right
so sheet
here
motion it
okay to
us
else scratch
that what do you mean
scratch oh
okay okay the motion is inexpedient to
legislate is uh anybody would like to
discuss we're we are on House Bill
79 relative to privatization of the
Liquor
Commission yeah we
did okay any discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to
legislate all set with your
conversations over
there okay the motion is inexpedient to
legislate clerk will call the role pusk
yes Osborne yes Ammon yes Cole yes post
is yes Peli yes wal is out miles yes
Pressa burrow yes Herbert yes M leer yes
spear yes Gibbs yes Sullivan Teresa s
out and chairman hunt
yes okay and motion carries vote 16 to
zip all those in favor placing on the
consent Calendar please say I I those
opposed so moved
unanimously okay last but certainly not
least
276 we don't no we should have the
requirement two
yeah okay so we doing
burrow uh right yes yes no I don't care
just get it
just you can
vot we have
anathe I'll let you
do
okay all right it right so uh
representative hunt seconded by
representative burough moves inexpedient
to
legislate I want to own this
one and I do know what the two vote no
vote three no votes are going to be
because I am a chairman and I should
always be able to count
votes okay the clerk will call the role
pusk yes
Osborne
no um excuse me Ammon
no Cole
yes post is yes prelli yes Walsh is out
miles
no Pressa
yes
burrow yes Herbert yes Maier
no spear yes Gibbs yes yes Sullivan
no
jassa
no and svia is not
here well I guess I was
wrong four five six seven eight here and
then we have
one and Keith was not so I'm going to do
an
X so this is 9 to eight
8 is that yes or no so that uh inex
legislate passes 98 will there be a
Minority
Report
okay regular calendar yes yes will be
yeah okay with that we'll end the exec
session so
didn't
this was
a we we did that one last week why
we just there is one correction she
forgot my vote so it it's going to be 10
to8 10 to8 10
to8 okay but there is aning majority one
two we have two be
right you have two check off where 10
who's not here oh see you wrote checked
over here okay so o is there's that's
your check put a check there oh okay so
I did it wrong right and this would be
key and this is Walsh is out right right
that's right correct miles the no so she
goes here
okay and this Mair was
here and then
Gibbs Gibbs was here and this is
Sullivan that's correct and this is
chasa and Sal's out the
actual
e
e e
hey Mac yeah I got one this is the last
two this is the Cannabis
pills
e
e e
all right we'll open up the public
hearing at house go 186 and here from
the prime sponsor representative
Sullivan good afternoon representative
Sullivan
good afternoon chairman hunt and
everybody else on my fellow committee um
we've all been here before and we've H
us out a bunch in the last couple years
and uh my motivation behind this bill is
many uh first and foremost I think it's
ridiculous we continue to arrest people
in New Hampshire for possession of
cannabis and I think that needs to stop
and so this is one of two bills I put in
the other one was in front of Criminal
Justice where they um are just the part
that legalizes it this does legalization
plus sale and regulation of the Commerce
part of it which is why it's here this
bill is largely modeled on the bill that
we passed uh close to unanimously out of
our committee in
2023 and then we overwhelmingly passed
it out of the house in 2023 as well I
think it was 290 votes or something I
don't remember the exact vote um so
basic Bally it was 53030 I think it was
539 back in uh
2023 so a few differences is we are just
going to use the room and meals tax um
so we will still have a very low tax
rate on it I think uh in the previous
Bill if I recall um it was more like the
beer model where we were going to be
taxing like cultivation but there
there's problems with doing it that way
particularly if it becomes legal
federally um cultivation could be moving
out of state um there's a lot of lot a
lot of reasons into why I thought just
the r runin meals tax would be better it
would be consider it would be
undercutting all of our neighbors so in
the same way that we attract a lot of
alcohol sales here from neighboring
states that have more expensive uh
alcohol products we would hopefully be
doing the same here in the way that
right now New Hampshire money is leaving
to go to our neighboring states because
we don't have it legal we would start
attracting some other states
residents to come here because our
products would presumably be cheaper
because the tax regime would be a lot
lower than they are in Massachusetts
Vermont Maine it would be whatever the
state's room meals tax right now that is
8 and a half% so unless that were to
change um it would be the lowest of
lowest of all the states uh in New
England um a few things in here so we
have a independent cannabis commission
so um
this
commission you this is on uh page 11 so
this commission would would be
established and you can see starting on
line 10 the various experts that would
be
appointed um the the governor would be
in charge of creating this Advisory
Board and this uh I worked with a lot of
the various interests in this in this
this sphere to help create the various
um experts that we would need to have
this commission created so that we could
hopefully have um really sensible
regulations because this while it's a
bill to legalize and regulate at some
level there's going to be a lot of Ru
making required to get into the
nitty-gritty that isn't able to be done
in this bill and this this commission
will be the ones that do that they're
the ones that that are the same way that
we have plenty of rule making in all
other industries that we regulate um
as far as
um expenses there will be some expenses
going out right away uh to start start
establishing this but you know within a
couple years we should start having some
licenses and and hopefully start U
selling selling cannabis to start
bringing in in additional Revenue into
the state um and eventually this would
become a profitable industry for the
state but certainly there would be an
upfront
expenditure
um one of the things that while
I'm I'm not I mean I would I would love
to see
um I'm not that concerned
about public smoking myself I think you
know to the extent that we allow people
smoking cigarettes in
public I I I don't see the harm in this
uh i' I've heard loud and clear from
many people that I
who that would be a deal breaker for
them that is in here so that you you
know we' be prohibited from smoking in
public um and so hopefully that will
address one of the concerns that I heard
from numerous people who were kind of on
the fence not on this committee but in
conversations on in the other body as
well as members in our in our own body
um so that's one of the things that
wasn't exactly what I was looking for
but I thought that was a a reasonable
compromise to make because people were
conc concerned about that um let me see
any other high
levels
um yeah I think with that I can open up
to some questions
um hopefully I can get the support on
this committee and hopefully in in our
house I know it's going to be a tough
year I'm I'm not going through life with
rosecolor glasses about the environment
with respect to cannabis legalization at
the state but the house has often been
able to push out good bills on this
subject and I hope that we can do so
again this year U the majority of people
in New Hampshire want it and I think if
we continue to push out good bills when
the environment is suitable hopefully
we'll have a good framework by which to
legalize cannabis in New Hampshire thank
you represent
shm uh so did I understand correctly
when he said
uh public smoking of uh cannabis will
still not be permitted that's under this
bill correct yeah that yeah it be it
would be prohibited and I think there's
a a fine a fine schedule in here that
you could look at first fine I think
it's $100 it could go up to 500 after
two or three um it'd be like a
misdemeanor wouldn't be it be a fine
misdemeanor situation you wouldn't be
arrested and convicted and become a
felon or anything like that but yeah
there'd be some sort of penalty
associated with it can I can I ask a
follow question further question me
inquire so uh is will will it also not
permitted uh to uh to smoke cannabis in
restaurants and
uh no I mean right now you can't even
smoke cigarettes in restaurants so that
certainly wouldn't be allowed office
yeah no so anywhere that you can't smoke
you can't smoke any marijuana uh oh
sorry anywhere you can't smoke tobacco
you wouldn't suddenly be allowed to
smoke marijuana alone but off office
spaces there are designated areas where
people can smoke cigarettes will they
permitted to smoke there you talking
about designated smokeing designated
smoking area uh I would I would say
probably not I mean that's not
specifically defined in here I think the
intent and and that that could be maybe
fleshed out in the ru making part of
this I mean I think so I think that
would go against the intent of why I put
that in here because and I'm not sure
that this is accurate it I've heard
mixed
uh mixed evidence of this so perhaps
it's unsettled at this moment in terms
of the science on it
but I heard from a few people who ID
hoped to gain support by putting this me
this language in there that they're
concerned about secondhand smoke if
somebody's smoking marijuana because so
long as it remains a legal federally it
could potentially make somebody who
isn't smoking unable to pass a drug test
and that would be something that would
be a problem for anything that requires
a drug test for federal positions
whether whether or not that's true from
the science perspective I wasn't able to
like consistently find one answer one or
the one way or the other so maybe it's
sort of like it's theoretically possible
so yeah this would a designated smoking
area at an office for example would go
against the spirit of what we're trying
to accomplish here which is to prevent
people from inhaling secondhand smoke of
it where obviously a designated smoking
area if I walk through I could
theoretically inhale something um so can
I ask another follow quick Qui quick
followup further
question so if I
correctly so in the office space that's
area they cannot smoke
marijuana can they smoke marijuana and
come to the
office you could smoke marijuana at home
and come to the office so long as I mean
that's not breaking a law I mean maybe
you shouldn't do that maybe you
shouldn't do that for a work reason but
uh yeah I mean it's not it's not illegal
to be high in public if that's the
question you're
asking I think he's asking is it okay
for the employer to Bar anybody from
being stoned when they come to work uh I
think that would be similar I think yes
I think a a corporation could certainly
pass a rule or their own policy where
you know we don't want somebody to be
drunk or high when when employed by us
while on the clock I think that's a fair
rule but this doesn't touch that that's
sort of a private
company's um
policies thank
you representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um
representative celan first of all I want
to compliment you um I think this bill
um is an improvement on the previous
bill from the last session uh both in
the creation of a cannabis commission
and in the way the bill bases the
Cannabis tax on the rooms and meals tax
um I have one really minor question um
in the bill there is a reference and I
can't tell you where it is because I
read the bill last night on my iPad um
but there's a reference to reporting to
The Liquor Commission um am I right in
thinking that that should say report to
the Cannabis commission yes so it's not
set up right now to report to the Liquor
Commission uh I don't remember reading
that when I saw that so I might have
missed that because that was not the
intent initially thank
you guess we're all set all right thank
you chair Colin Heath Howard who is a
co-sponsor
thank you Mr chairman and fellow
committee members uh my name is
representative Heath Howard I represent
the towns of straford and barington and
straford District 4 uh I come in front
of you today in support of HB uh 186
because it to me is pretty common sense
right now we've been seeing huge Revenue
declines and this is a great way that we
can help kind of climb out of that hole
without introducing new tax burdens onto
our public it also gives people new
Liberties which I do believe that they
should have access to in being able to
possess cannabis as representative
Sullivan had said it has nothing to do
with public use of cannabis and would
still Outlaw that uh as uh this has been
kind of a uh a point that I had made a
point on uh during the the floor debate
uh last session I had spoken in
opposition uh to uh some change that
would prevent any sort or would impose a
ban on public uh smoking or vaping uh
I've since compromised on that part of
the issue and am willing to uh try and
work to get this through in any way
possible uh so again it's not
necessarily what I would have preferred
or would have wanted but it's something
that I think that we can get across the
finish line and at least get to the
governor's desk thanks
any questions from the committee
members seeing none thank you very much
thank
you uh well we have another Sullivan Pat
Sullivan the Hampshire Association of
chiefs of
police thank you chairman hunt and uh
representative suvan I are not related
so there's no domestic dispute
my name is Patrick suvin I'm the
executive director for the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police I'm
currently serving my 43rd year in law
enforcement I am the retired police
chief of
gtown the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police opposes
the legalization of marijuana marijuana
is a scheduled one drug and it is still
illegal New Hampshire continues to
experience an opio crisis the New
Hampshire Chiefs of police have
identified several areas of concern from
Public Safety perspective surrounding
the legalization of marijuana the
operating of vehicles and the inability
to test uh for legal limits um that's a
huge concern for Public Safety um
protecting law enforcement profession um
currently a person cannot possess a
firearm under federal law while using
marijuana or having used marijuana
if portions of this law are enacted or
this bill are enacted it would require
police
officers to be able to use marijuana and
have a
firearm um hom grow will remove any
potential revenue and will saturate the
state with untested uncontrolled
marijuana the analment section we
believe is unnecessary language there
was already a process in place for an
nments which review the case and
circumstances in a
totality finally the restricting of
denial of employment for the use of
marijuana endangers all Granite Staters
from the police officer wearing a
firearm as I previously mentioned the
commercial truck operator to the pilot
and the driver of our children's school
buses that's a concern for that we
should all have concerning our children
and our communities thank
you representative Herbert has a
question in terms of uh the
potency of uh the various strains of
marijuana are they uh greater
or uh less potent than previous
strains when you say previous strains
and we're talking back in the 70s um
I've heard it's 80 90% stronger um and I
don't have the exact numbers but as I
understand it this the potency is much
stronger representative
shares so I just wanted to understand
the bill better and your concern about
what you just
said uh will legalization under this
bill is it going to make it uh uh okay
for people police officers or people to
to use it and go on job is that what you
understand
this bill says you cannot be
impaired on the job the employer can
affect job action against you if you're
impaired on the
job but with Federal firearm laws you
can't use marijuana and possess a
firearm okay thank you representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um doesn't the
bill make it illegal
to use to operate uh a vehicle or an
airplane or anything similar uh under
the influence of
marijana yes it does however what is the
limit that's part of the driving thing
there is no legal standard or limit what
makes you
impaired there's no judging that there's
no testing
that representative pusc thank you Mr
chair
[Music]
um Mr Sullivan uh I was reading an
article in the Wall Street Journal the
other day about
THC the
THC uh from back in my day in 60s and
70s was about
6% the THC of the 21st century tested
last year was
90% just FYI would you believe I would
and thank you I that's well within lines
of what I've been hearing
but representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair uh this is
basically a follow up on on my previous
question um can you tell us anything
about how other states that have
legalized marijuana um determine whether
um a driver uh is impaired after using
marijuana there are several different
programs aide
um such as those detection classes
um again we have very limited resources
here in New Hampshire as far as training
the number of police officers that need
that
certification represent
spear I know that at BAE Systems of
course you can't you can't go to work
over there but that's a federal those
are federal contracts but is there
anything stopping the police from saying
you we don't want you to have uh
marijuana I mean can't they just say as
an employer under
this yeah bill it says it cannot be
discriminate you cannot as an employer
discriminate and so you're taking that
to mean that you can't you can't say
have you been using
marijuana or you can't discriminate a
upon past convictions if I
recall oh boy we have another round repr
Teresa so uh based on your experience so
far uh the states where they have
legalized the neighboring state
Massachusetts Maine
Vermont from the police department
perspective have they seen increase in
criminalization or increase in law
breaking or disruption that you that you
are concerned about they've seen
increases in impaired driving um
increases in
fatals as far as the employment portion
I can't speak to that I I don't know and
I I I won't even my question more for
for the public have have so they you did
say that they have seen increase in uh
criminalization or accidents or correct
from the public yes thank
you representative Gibbs thank you um
under the bill um can't an employer say
uh that employees uh cannot be high
while on the job yes they can say that
absolutely but again what is the
standard of being high on the
job thank you very much thank you we got
one more card
left Dr Joe
Hannon another former member of the
House Commerce
Committee thank you for the introduction
chairman uh my name is Joe Hannon um I
served on the governance commission to
regulate uh the commission to regulate
Taxation and uh sale of marijuana at the
time uh back in 2018 I think it was 18
uh and I'm also on the board of New
Hampshire cannabis Association on their
Advisory Board um I stand in favor of
this bill it's it's very similar I'm
sure if you flip through it you wouldn't
see it too different than bills that had
passed this Committee in the house at
least once in the past probably more
than that um I think it's a good start
uh one thing I I didn't find I was
listening to other people testifying I
couldn't find anything in this bill that
says that people have to use cannabis
like you cops don't have to start using
it and Pilots don't have to start using
it you don't have to do it this isn't
making anyone do anything it's giving
someone a choice um and they can be
prevented from those positions if they
are under the influence especially
because of federal law being what it is
so I don't I don't think that's really
an issue uh in 2022 the national survey
on drug use uh and health about half of
us adults uh 50.3% were found to have
used cannabis at some point in their
lives I'm not going to ask anyone in
here to raise hands but that would be
about
10.3 of you uh that would be have at
least used it once in your lives in 2023
it was estimated there were 55 a. half
million us adults who had used at least
once in the previous
year okay now Lincoln once said that in
paraphrasing the best way to to get a
bad law repealed is to enforce it
strictly cannabis laws are not enforced
strictly obviously and they're certainly
not enforced fairly you're five times
more likely and sometimes six times
depending on your jurisdiction more
likely to be arrested for cannabis
missed a possession offense if you are a
person of color or other minority so
it's not it's not uniformly um enforced
if 55 million Americans were rounded up
and sent to prison for up to seven and a
half years for their first defense there
wouldn't be just uh a protest or some
rioting there'd be another Revolution
that would make the one we did over the
1% Stamp Act look like peanuts you
couldn't lock up one out of seven people
in this country and not see consequences
but we have a long on the books that
everyone wants to enforce but not too
much because if they did it would we
would have the result of we wouldn't
have to listen to these bills every year
if it was actually enforced nobody would
be here discussing it it would be a
no-brainer
um and for roadside tests we only have a
roadside test for alcohol and that was
not even invented till almost 20 years
after prohibition was repealed initially
uh we don't have a roadside test for any
prescription drugs any over-the-counter
medications cold medication narcotics
lots of things that many millions and
millions of Americans are on on a daily
basis zero roadside test they have other
means of doing that I think it's good to
have uh you know drug enforcement ex
drug recognition experts and people out
there doing their job I think we need to
fund more of that that's a great thing
to keep people from driving impaired but
I think that um you know thinking that
we are an island of prohibition is a
good thing is is shortsighted we're
surrounded by not just every state
around us that is legalized it but
another country has legalized it we are
completely surrounded now that's great
we can say we a moral superiority to
them because we haven't legalized it
here but that's ignorant to think that
people can't drive 20 minutes or 30
minutes in any direction and buy it and
bring it right back that's what people
do we're losing the revenue we're making
people travel more so you don't want
people to drive under the influence but
we want them to drive further to get
it um you know it's okay to sell grain
alcohol or high uh content liquor in the
stores and the state does that as a as a
as a government entity so to speak and
that's not questioned whatsoever no no
one's saying well they sell grain that's
killing people well yeah it's not a good
idea to drink it and you shouldn't be
using high doses of high amounts of THC
unless you have a reason people are
going to do it but it also gives people
who smoke or inhale those products which
is still unfortunately a higher
percentage of people the ability to
smoke less you know if something is if
you're drinking a something that's 40%
alcohol you know if you have 10 drinks
that's a lot but you don't have to have
as many drinks if you're drinking
something that's stronger necessarily uh
same with pain medication when I
prescribe pain medic ation I would give
people sometimes a very strong pain
medication for severe pain but I would
give them the lowest dose possible and
you know someone instead of taking 10 15
20 pills a day if I can give them a
smaller dose of something that's a
better thing to do a smaller quantity um
anyway so no one's forcing people to do
it and as far as uh you know the federal
courts and second amendment rights there
have been at least two federal courts
that have said they can't do it hasn't
been in our district federal district
yet but the the trend is happening that
it's not something is constitutional and
I I can't wait for that debate to happen
at the federal level even further um and
I think that's about it unless you have
any questions I'd be happy to answer any
questions you have I've been doing this
for many years from an advocacy level
and I've worked with patients people in
recovery uh providers and people in the
business and obviously legislators and
I'd be happy to answer any questions or
concerns you may
have represent
Teresa so will this bill require a label
on the marijuana product being sold
saying marijuana is injurious to health
the way
alcohol uh that label is always there in
every alcohol product or even cigarette
smoking products will this require to
put that label so people know that it is
injurious to help that
is um there are there are several I
don't I can't find the specific sentence
thank you for your question I I don't
know the specific part of this that says
that but there are several areas that
have
um Market Mass marketing prohibitions
Pro marketing to miners uh labeling
requirements about content uh and that
that effect I don't know if there's a
specific health warning maybe someone
else could answer that it it may be in
here but uh I'm not sure followup
question not against it further question
and uh as we just heard the testimony
from the law enforcement will this bill
all require uh some guideline or some uh
restriction
that uh they a person can have only so
much amount of
marijuana to be not impaired or to be
like for example in alcohol they say in
driving school that you can have one
drink an hour and it'll go away from a
system so is this going to set any
guideline like that standard that this
is how much a person can have consume
within certain time frame not more than
that for a law enforcement to be able to
get alerted something like that the
education or something like that it's
it's I I believe it comes to the most
people without with alcohol it's not ex
a perfectly linear relationship but for
a certain size and weight we can fairly
estimate fairly well how impaired
someone is generally by how many drinks
they have per body weight with cannabis
that's not the case people do react
differently someone who is a regular
medical user even just recreational user
may be using higher Doses and that may
affect them differently um it may affect
stronger or even less they may be able
to handle it better uh there are some
people who think they can drive better
when they drink more and probably not a
not a good uh idea but um the fact that
people with uh cannabis use may have
something in their system means a blood
test might show elevated levels of
metabolites in their system that are not
necessarily indicative of being under
the influence so having a per se limit
like a specific number of what's
considered impaired you can't do now
because you can't do that
currently scientifically does that mean
that we shouldn't do this I mean after
prohibition was appealed it was a good
20 years before they even invented a
test and then it was another 20 or 30
years before that it was a good idea to
enforce it um we know it's not a good
idea but people that drive under the
influence of alcohol are 12 times more
likely than the average individual to
get into a traffic accident um and
people under the use of cannabis and I
don't have the exact number but I know
it's under 2% between one and two one
and two times more likely so it's
definitely more likely and I'm not
saying people should drive under the
influence but I'm saying it's not nearly
as dangerous as driving under the
influence of alcohol on a overall level
of just pure numbers now um the other
thing is people do drink less in some
location some areas especially young
people are obviously drinking less and
smoking more at certain certain times
now I'm not saying high school kids
because there's tons of studies that
show that High School aged uh use has
gone down in states of legalized medical
or adult use but um it
anyway I hope that answers your
question the answer your question about
what is written on the package for
disclosures is on page the bottom of
page 22 Yeah okay thank
you thank
you yep morning label caution when eaten
or swallowed the intoxicating effects of
this product may be
delayed
okay anything else are we good I was
able to find it pretty quickly I guess
this does look pretty familiar to me I
thought
so okay any other questions for Dr
Hannon seeing done thank you very much
have a great having no more cards oh
no I will close the public hearing on
House Bill
186 and like all bills in Commerce it
will go to a subcommittee and it's and
it's our liquor
subcommittee okay so for committee
members um I have scheduled next
Wednesday Tuesday's off Thursday is a
session day um after Wednesday we uh
theoretically uh haven't heard any
different that I have now scheduled all
bills we have we'll have all our
hearings done so so then as we go March
through the rest of the of the of of the
month we will be just doing
subcommittees and we getting through the
we getting through the weeds and of all
those
bills and I will try to do Tuesday
Wednesday um you know if I can get
community rooms on Tuesday but it's
really it's based upon availability
because I refuse to meet on
Friday thank you representative spear
read it there's something in there that
says you cannot you know especially on
on on crisis emergency something you
know you can't yeah you can't you can't
can't uh get crazy about charging you
know for that bottle of water